we're gonna jump to this next story
cancel culture baby
dilbert is racist popular comic strip is
canned by 77 newspapers after artist
scott adams began incorporating
anti-woke plot lines including black
character who identifies as white it's
brilliant good job scott um i mean
dude's speaking out speaking up and
using his platform
and they and they come they come for him
because of it now they do say over the
daily mail
gilbert strips featured in newspapers i
don't know what gilbert is but dilbert's
been around forever
and so he's got a bunch of these comics
one there's a guy and he's like dave i
need to boost our company's esg rating
so i'm promoting you to be our cto i
know you identify as white so that won't
help our asg scores but would it be too
much trouble to identify as gay it says
depending on how depends on how hard you
want me to sell it just wear better
shirts oh my gosh this is great
these comics are actually they're
hilarious so there's one where it's like
i don't know if it's in here
one of the comics is that they're
introducing a black character and he's
like i'd like to introduce uh you know
to our new uh employee who's gonna help
bring our esg score up and then the
black guy goes identify as white and
he's like you're ruining this so anyway
look
scott adams obviously has been outspoken
for a while now but directly
incorporating the stuff more and more
into his comics so what do they do they
can the comics but you know what
this says to me it's just winning i know
there's a lot of people who are like
you're getting canceled from newspapers
you think that's winning i do because
people like dilbert there's gonna be a
lot of people who are like yo where's
dilbert and i'm willing to bet
and and if you're a fan of dilbert i'm
willing to bet a lot of people are gonna
look at their newspapers the ones that
are still reading it and be like where's
gilbert and or the websites and they're
going to call up and be like hey where's
dilbert and they're going to be like oh
we were offended by it so we took it out
they're going to be like well i like it
bring it back well it also matters that
that you're here giving them more of a
platform too right like we talked about
the other side you get cancelled off one
side another side brings you up and rise
you up so
that's a good
you know doing the right thing with the
platform but also what what makes me
scared is
how the most powerful companies in the
world are the ones that are the locusts
right now that's that's concerning when
you look at who's
pushing
all the all the wokeness on us it's like
it's like disney it's like
it's like espn does it's like wow these
are like powerful powerful players
in media yeah concerning well that's
because of the esg score which he was
criticizing which he got cancelled for
criticizing and i think that's more to
why he got cancelled than any other
reason
just yesterday at the clinton global
initiative bill clinton was talking with
the heads of blackrock promoting esg as
somehow some kind of a great
accomplishment it's awesome it's great
no it's literally a ponzi scheme for
people to enrich themselves and push
ideas that divide and conquer people and
make them more dependent on the state
and and when you look at these funds
when you look at what what they're doing
it's absolutely sinister because they go
to major corporations and say hey you're
gonna promote this idea you're gonna
push this agenda you don't we're going
to cut your funding we're not going to
give you any money
and the corporations listen it's also
just going to bolster investment into
china
yeah absolutely i wonder how alphabet's
dealing with it the parent company of
youtube i haven't talked to anybody
there a parent company of google well
yeah which is a parent company of i
think alphabet owns youtube now i think
it's a separate company it could be
alphabet owns google which owns youtube
but i'd love if somebody out there
corporate wants to come on the show and
talk about it how you guys are dealing
with esg i'd love to hear it because
google alphabet's like one of the most
maybe the most powerful media company on
earth right now
the the woke cult the esg stuff only
operates as long as people don't know
about it once regular people find out
about it they get mad that's that's how
you end up with a republican winning in
virginia
because people didn't know was going on
schools they found out was going on
schools and then they were like okay i'm
voting against this and it was it was
suburban housewives they voted against
trump all of a sudden they see what's
going on they're like ah it's worse the
other direction
so
i think
this is why they got a censor it's why
they're so adamant about controlling
what you guys post or what other artists
post especially for bands this is why
i'm saying culture is so important
because people just want to be
entertained they want to have a good
time they want to relax they don't think
about work they don't think about
hardship they don't think about politics
they don't want to be brought down some
people do some people love doom
scrolling
but a lot of people they're like you
know again i'll shout out blue ridge
rock fest because we were there just a
couple weeks ago like two weeks ago and
the people who are there are like i want
to get out i want to get away right and
so that they go in mass to see tenacious
deeds in the rain
in the mud dude i think it's sprayed
down and we had fun
so good we had some points for you
brother come on my shoes
but so then they know that these people
up on stage at that moment have a lot of
influence because you can look at a
crowd and you can be singing and then
you point the microphone and everyone
the crowd knows it's their turn to start
singing so you go up on stage and pull
up john lennon and say this war in
ukraine is bs and we shouldn't be
involved and people are going to be like
do i cheer for that or like would i i
like this band so i'm in i guess
that's what they didn't like about john
lennon and that's why i think tv shows
you know movies actors the arts they
they locked that down and made sure
everybody was marching in lockstep they
tried but john was unstoppable man could
not be stopped dude
he was still everyone stopped eventually
you know everyone dies eventually but
john lennon was he was so famous that
the media couldn't stop like they would
still go to his apartment with him and
yoko in bed like what was it asleep in
for peace they were doing like yeah when
that happens they get ready it seems
he was stopped i mean i don't know
there's a bunch of wild theories but i
can just say that some some way or
another like dude was stopped
by john mark chapman you mean or is that
mark david david john mark chapman who
knows that mark david chapman yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know i mean maybe
maybe someone sent chapman after him
maybe because he was so anti-war or chad
it was just crazy you start thinking
when you when you get when you dive so
deep into the layers of of
you you know obviously listening to the
show hanging out with you guys you you
you're getting informed right you're
learning more
you start questioning everything that
you see when you see lennon's death when
you start when you start putting
pieces together of of influential people
that have passed away and
the messages that they were standing for
anytime someone's uniting people
bringing people together going anti-war
they don't last very long and and you
and it makes you start really wondering
like wow like am i a conspiracy theorist
or
is this just how it is when you get too
influential where you're bigger than the
media you're larger than life you're
spreading this message that's bringing
people together people love making
people love each other jackson
yeah
yeah kurt cobain become a problem kurt
cobain had a tweet where he said he had
evidence that would lead to the arrest
of him
and then you know what uh martin luther
king jr actually uh his family filed a
civil someone's gonna flip that that was
a joke
media matter is gonna be like tim paul
thinks kurt cobain had twitter
the uh i think it was uh martin luther
king jr's family filed a civil suit
against the fbi for a wrongful death
didn't they like send him a letter
telling him to kill himself or something
that was the fbi under their cointelpro
program when mlk was in jail they they
actually called his wife
and played the audio recordings of mlk
cheating on his wife and they also sent
letters to mlk in jail saying kill
yourself um
so this is this is what this is what the
fbi but this is what the fbi was doing
decades ago and not much has changed
what was it the cia's the heart attack
gun
uh yes that was with uh the commission
this is why people think breitbart was
killed because he was really young and
he was extremely influential a lot of
drugs too for sure for sure i heard he
was a big partier right right right
right right but i'm saying the reason
people i'm not saying he was killed i'm
saying the reason people think it is
because you have someone influential in
politics and then you go back five
decades and they have a heart attack gun
and you're like yeah okay well it's
possible i guess
and it's really funny because then the
media like
you can cite the media and then the me
and then other journalists will then
claim you're espousing conspiracy
theories it's the weirdest thing you'd
be like hey look at this story in the
new york times about a heart attack gun
and then they'll they'll write a story
about you saying you're an unhinged
conspiracy theory talking about heart
attack guns and it's like i was just
reading the newspaper dude come on man
leave me alone you know yeah but i
wonder what you guys listening think do
you think like lenin you know john
lennon and like jfk were were removed
you know or i mean obviously they both
were but was it like overt high-level
politics or was it lone weirdos well now
when you see the media you get behind
something so hard like some of the some
of the things we've seen like i even
brought it up the other day like and i
know that this is a bad example but but
it makes you think of the dc sniper
right that guy that was just on the side
picking picking people off
once you start seeing how much the media
went in on that story you when does the
media go that in on something unless
they want to manipulate
the tale of the story right
so
it makes you start thinking like
was that guy exiled right was he in the
system at some point learned some
information exiled out like is that
another instance of this like
you you start looking at all the things
in your life that you're growing up for
me one of them is jfk lennon's another
one you got chris cornell you got uh
chester from lincoln park you you you
hear rumors about some of the things
that they had going on in a sense of of
really trying to help eliminate child
trafficking and and this is real man
these are these are stories that we're
hearing from their families from people
we know that know them
they were heavily involved in really
helping
you know they were going to be they were
playing children
yeah and then and then they disappear so
it's like it's like i'm sure it's it's a
it's a give and take some of it happened
some of it didn't but you start
questioning it all dude charles manson's
another interesting when he was part of
mk ultra i believe it was mk ultra out a
book about it this guy wrote this
massive book he's been on rogan multiple
times let's fact check if that's correct
here because we know the unabomber was a
part of the mkultra programs which are
secret
uh programs by the cia that was doing
horrific human experiments trying to
figure out mind control so this is done
documented on the record your tax
dollars went towards the cia and they
experimented on a lot of people who were
unsuspecting subjects and they were
given acid they were given a whole bunch
of drugs that they couldn't handle a lot
of people even died under cia
experimentation but the cia decades and
decades ago all the way in the 60s and
70s was working on controlling people's
minds and getting them to do things for
them
so this is not a conspiracy this is this
is real this is this happens all my
family and friends listening right now
you get your minds blown aren't you this
way
this uh the guardian has this article
chaos charles manson the cia in the
secret history of the 60s by tom o'neill
with dan pipenbring review i think there
was a book and i i'll see if i can find
the book title did the cia's lsd labs
make manson the crazy because he would
like get arrested and then they would
let him out and then he'd go and get
arrested again and they'd let him out
again you know not like that like that
never happens i know but
here's here's kaczynski and the
unabomber was the big one thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you